[Música]
[Aplausos]
ya de chiquito era muy curioso recuerdo
cuando estaba en quinto o sexto grado
del colegio primario con un compañerito
decidimos fabricar un motorcito
eléctrico para ponerlo en el fuselaje de
una avioneta con corchos alambres clavos
bueno claramente no funcionó terminamos
desarmando una licuadora para poner ese
motor en el fuselaje de la avioneta
también me acuerdo que por las mañanas
iba a biblioteca a buscar experimentos
mira con un cuadernito los anotaba volví
a mi casa y trataba de replicar los el
típico experimento de de la alhambra
enrollando un clavito para fabricar un
electroimán con una batería o el clásico
el peine que te lo frotaba en el pulóver
para traer papelitos siendo con ese
perfil sin colegio secundario técnico y
ya llegando al último año sexto año con
la mayoría de los compañeros y vamos a
estudiar ingeniería electrónica
pero ese diciembre aparecieron en el
curso o dos personas hablando de una
carrera nueva diferente era estudiantes
de bioingeniería
y fue tan atractiva y motivante esa
charla que me moví 200 kilómetros a oro
verde a estudiar bioingeniería
y si me encontré con un mundo totalmente
apasionante y muy motivante
dije ese ese enero mientras hacia la
mudanza me dije ya está ya está me voy a
mudar si voy a fracasar que se en algo
diferente y desafiante
y bueno ya como estudiantes de
bioingeniería recuerdo una charla de un
investigador un argentino que está
investigando en francia y nos preguntaba
si sabíamos si el mundo estaba buscando
alcanzar unas fronteras productivas y
nos hablaba de las diferentes
revoluciones industriales
la primera revolución industrial fue la
de la máquina vapor por ejemplo la
segunda revolución industrial la más
importante fue la de la electricidad
la tercera revolución industrial la más
contemporánea la más actual fue la de
las computadoras e internet y digo fue
porque esta revolución industrial se
acabó no pintura no continua más se
terminó
está bien ustedes me pueden decir que
los dispositivos electrónicos para
entretenimiento y comunicación son cada
vez más chiquitos más inteligentes más
rápidos
pero no tiene ni punto de comparación
del impacto económico que genera comprar
un libro en internet que lo que fue la
invención de la luz eléctrica
dicen muchos de los investigadores de
los países más desarrollados de los
especialistas que la nueva revolución
industrial la cuarta revolución
industrial
va a estar dada por las innovaciones
aplicadas a la búsqueda de soluciones a
la problemática de la salud y acá nos
encontramos con la nanotecnología
biotecnología tecnología médica genética
inteligencia artificial
por ejemplo con la nanotecnología se
están logrando avances enormes y cuando
hablo de nanotecnología este prefijo
nano es la milmillonésima parte de algo
es algo muy muy muy muy chiquito
imagínense más de mil veces más chicos
que el espesor de un cabello humano
bueno con la nanotecnología se han
logrado desarrollar nano máquinas para
atacar exclusivamente moléculas células
cancerígenas evitando así los efectos
secundarios de las terapias
tradicionales
y se de revoluciones estamos hablando
a nivel personal comencé con mi
revolución cuando tenía 34 años
era un día 28 de abril del año 2014 un
día lluvioso frío
feo
estaba yo en el consultorio de un médico
a neurocirujano
y el médico tenía en sus manos una
resonancia mía del cerebro
la pone contra la luz
y se evidenciaban muchas manchas blancas
y yo le vi una sonrisa al médico
claramente había encontrado algo
baja la resonancia y me dice tenés
esclerosis múltiple
no sabía qué decir no sabía qué hacer no
sabía lo que era
no entendía lo que era
no obstante eso vuelve a levantar la
resonancia la pone contra la luz y me
dice mira aparecería qué tumor no s
puedo bajar la resonancia se me acerca y
me pregunta vos si dan o tienen
ese mediodía volvía a mi casa
abrace a mi señor y lloramos durante dos
horas
pero fue un santo muy fuerte no sé nunca
había llorado así un profundo y visceral
la esclerosis múltiple es una enfermedad
del sistema nervioso central autoinmune
esto es las células no se reconocen a sí
mismas y se atacan crónica
discapacitante y que no tiene cura
aparecen brotes o ataques sin previo
aviso
y por lo general alguna secuela de ja
a mí me dejó muchos mareos
y me estaba viendo en la marcha falta de
equilibrio y mucha mucha mucha fatiga
esto es la batería de mi cuerpo nunca se
termina de llenar y además se descarga
con mucha facilidad
cambio la configuración de mi cuerpo
me tuve que hacer amigos de la
esclerosis múltiple tuve que aprender a
vivir con esclerosis múltiple
y hoy en día cuento aquel episodio del
diagnóstico en el que el médico me habla
de estas tres opciones lo cuento de
manera tragicómica digo que me dio
elegir entre estas cartas en la primera
carta estaba la parca andando en
patineta en la segunda carta estaba la
parca jugando al tenis y la tercera
carta la parca tomando un daiquiri
claramente elegí la parca tomando en
alquiler
cambiaron mis prioridades busco pasar
más tiempo con mis familias con mis
amigos con los afectos
aprendí a nadar
por es el único deporte que mi cuerpo me
permite hacer porque al entrar en calor
el cuerpo los síntomas se potencian y el
agua y el agua
claramente ayuda a disipar la
temperatura y hasta compito en algunos
torneos
escalar el cerro champaquí junto a mi
prima y uno de mis mejores amigos
y cuando hicimos sima nuevamente la
lágrima se hizo presente
y con el tiempo el peso inicial de esa
lágrima lo fuerte de esa lágrima inicial
se fue atenuando se fué alivianando
fue perdiendo ese peso
y nuevamente la lágrima estamos haciendo
una lluvia de ideas en el laboratorio
donde investigó junto a colegas bio
ingenieros investigadores y oftalmólogos
y estamos hablando a mostrándole nuestra
tecnología estamos viendo si a partir de
esta tecnología podríamos abordar
problemas de la salud ocular
y así surgió la brillante idea
la brillante idea de diagnosticar
enfermedades oculares enfermedades del
ojo utilizando tan solo una lágrima
y hoy en día
desarrollamos un primer prototipo de un
dispositivo médico que cumple con estas
características y esto abre un mundo
totalmente nuevo y desconocido
imagínense que podamos distinguir entre
lágrimas de alegría y lágrimas de
tristeza esto es futuro estamos creando
la cuarta revolución industrial
y la profesión me ayudó y me ayuda mucho
a transitar la enfermedad y además se
encuentro varios puntos en común
por un lado la incertidumbre los
desconocidos de las tecnologías en la
búsqueda de soluciones a los problemas
de salud y por otro lado la
incertidumbre y la duda permanente que
significa vivir con esclerosis múltiple
yo no sé lo que va a pasar mañana
pero a la vez la claridad y la certeza
de que el mejor momento es ahora
no es más tarde no es mañana es hoy y es
ahora
y después de intimidarme lejos de
intimidarme la esclerosis múltiple me
ayudó a vivir con más con más intensidad
y todos los días
todos los días me recuerda que estoy
vivo gracias
[Aplausos]